hi hey we need to talk
what Wow bitchin huh I think I've seen
you before
didn't you spoke coffee all over hearing
me yeah did you pay for yours because
she paid for ours weren't you the server
at their wedding
wait yeah you were a free did you get
this jacket from her no mine mine is a
one-of-a-kind so was this when you let
me borrow it
who are you I'm your daughter Nora from
the future and I think I made a big big
mistake
I found Thomas he's in this way Oh what
the hell is that all about hey everybody
it's Charlie this is gonna be my flash
season 5 video so just careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the flash
finale yet but obviously I tried to put
a little buffer there at the beginning
of the video but there were a couple key
scenes that teased what's gonna be
happening who the villain is going to be
some of it actually got cut for time so
I'll explain there are some deleted
scenes that they meant to give you they
were meant to tell you what's going on
in season 5 that they said that they
would release at Comic Con so I'll
explain what those scenes were and which
cast members are coming back they
confirmed a couple characters as you
expected will be coming back for season
5 so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
DC videos there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on the video and I'll also
explain a little bit about the summer
schedule with Titans because we're gonna
get everything at comic-con for Titans
in flash season 5 and all other DC
things but Titans as a series is going
to drop before we get the flash season 5
so just keep that in the back of your
mind as we're talking about flash season
5 stuff but we got to talk all about
noir Allen and who the villain of season
5 is going to be and what her big
mistake was that we're calling
flashpoint 2.0 so well do this is a top
10 list the way I do every year so
number 10 prediction we will find out
who the villain is for next season at
Comic Con because the deleted scene that
was going to tell us that which is cut
for time the producer said that they did
intend on releasing it and I think that
it will have something to do with Jenna
Murray West Joe and Cecile's baby
because they said it would be a very
family centric storyline for season 5
for both Caitlin and for both what's
going on with Norah in the mistake that
she made if they also said that the
villain would not be a speedster but
they didn't say that they wouldn't be
related to a speedster it's just like
it's not going to be another evil
speedster like zoom or reverse flash but
don't worry there will be other
speedsters but number 9 they also say
that Norris mistake does have something
to do with the season 5 villain like
think about how Barry created
avatar when he created flashpoint so the
producers teased that this mistake that
she made that she's talking about is
specifically tied to four times that she
came back into the past to meet members
of Team flash but it's not the only
reason so on my finale video a lot of
people were wondering if her helping
barry destroy the satellite was part of
the mistake they didn't address that
they only specified the four times that
she came back into the past to meet
members of team flash like number one
she came back as the server at the
wedding to watch Barry and iris get
married - she paid for Cisco and Ralph's
coffee the third time was when she
spilled coffee on Caitlin and Harry then
the fourth time was when she came back
for Joe and Cecile's baby shower to give
them that gift for Jenna Marie so I
think the idea that they're trying to
put forth is that she made a mistake in
the future the producers also explained
where she's from the timeline which was
really cool them she made a mistake and
then in coming to the past she made it
worse
like she keeps making it worse so
finally she has to come to Barry
directly which is something that she
probably didn't want to do so it is a
little bit like flashpoint 2.0 Barry
creates flashpoint tries to fix it when
he fixes it he finds that things are
still really bad with the team so he
tries to go back a third time but Jay
Garrick stops him and gives him that
coffee cup explainer this is sort of the
point that we've reached with Nora's
character which is why she seems so
tired like hey you know I'm happy to be
here but I also did something really
really bad and I need your help so I
don't think that she came back
specifically just to save Barry from the
satellite people are wondering about
when she was born in you know what would
have happened if Barry died does this
has something to do with her existing as
a person so number seven also you know
we will see where she comes from in the
future that is thirty years she came
back thirty years into the past
so her present day in the future is the
year 2048 very close to that 2056
message from Barry in the future from
legends of tomorrow last year the thing
about that that's also a bit of an
anachronism - because that was part of
the Sabbat our plot line wheres avatar
was jumping around in the timeline so
Barry had probably done something in the
future but remember the 2024 flash
vanishes in crisis future newspaper
from the pilot that's arguably when
berry is supposed to die that's not
supposed to happen you know in real time
till season 10 of the TV show this date
here April 2025 is basically the season
10 finale so in this future time where
she's from Barrie has been dead but
she's grown up being a spacer she was
born with speed powers so she's been the
flash a lot longer than Barry has been
the flash and a lot of you may have
realized this really funny detail about
her too so Jessica Parker Kennedy is the
name of the actress that's playing Nora
she's about six years older than Grant
Gustin in real life even though she
looks a little bit younger so imagine
that she's born sometime before crisis
on Infinite Earths per this future
newspaper but she grows up with Barry
being dead and iris being a single
mother with Wally being the main version
of the flash then eventually at some
point in the future when she becomes an
adult she takes the mantle from Wally
and she becomes the main version of the
flash so for those of you wondering why
she's just as fast if not faster than
Barry that's why she just had like an
extra 20 years over Barry to learn about
her speed abilities so number five this
future timeline why she reacts badly to
Iris and certain other members of team
flash like Caitlin or Harrison Wells has
to do with her relationship with those
characters in the future so I think it's
pretty easy to assume why she might not
like Harrison wells in why she might not
be so hot on Caitlin because in the
future Caitlin probably becomes more
evil full-blown killer frost she might
be familiar with the eobard thawne
version of Harrison wells or there might
be some Harry from another earth that
becomes evil in the future but there are
a number of very practical reasons to
explain why she might not be so hot on
iris because if Barry was dead in the
future and she was a single mom think
about how Barry dying would affect iris
in the way that iris raises her daughter
so we'll let tumblr theorize on iris
West nor Allen relationship theories but
they'll get into that during next season
number four the Caitlin teaser and
Thomas asks her father I think we've all
landed on that person as being the
father that we don't know about because
they showed us a picture of him in
season three but we never learned what
his name was so on earth - Caitlin snow
had a brother that died his name was
Charlie just like my name but on earth
one Caitlyn grew up an only child in the
interview that II W did with the
producers they specifically theorized
with them that she killed her father in
the past so I don't think they would
have specifically added that to their
discussion with the producers if they
weren't trying to imply that there was
gonna be some guilt the Caitlyn had
during season five her season five arc
will be all about her family but number
three some of you'll be really happy
about this they confirmed that Ralph is
coming back next season I don't know for
how many episodes or if he's gonna be
main character or he'll be recurring
like Jessie quick but they also
confirmed top Cavanaugh is coming back
as a different version of Harrison wells
they didn't say what's gonna happen to
earth to Harry he just goes back to
earth-2 at the end of the episode so we
might see him again but they implied
that the Harrison wells that we'll meet
during season five is gonna be someone
else from a different earth bringing it
back around to number two Jay Garrick
says that he's gonna be training a
female speedster so if jessie quick is
gonna stay on earth too
we just met a female speedster this
seems like she's gonna be a recurring
character in future seasons if things go
well when they fix things in the future
they just explained that she goes off to
earth three and helps out Jay Garrick
with that earth so that every once in a
while she can come back and team up with
the flash for a big crossover but number
one big thing that they set up in the
first episode in the last episode but
didn't completely pay off Harrison wells
drawing those Speed Force symbols they
just pull him away and then they never
address it again like literally there's
just all these Speed Force symbols
sitting on the board behind him here
that they don't reference those are the
same symbols that appeared on des Vosges
blackboard right after he first became
the thinker the same symbols that Nora
was writing in her journal in the copy
shop that will probably have something
to do with defeating the season five
villain in addition to sort of fixing
their family I think it's gonna be a
very flash family-centric story which is
why I think that the season 5 villain in
the mistake also has something to do
with Jenna Marie West because otherwise
why would you make such a big deal about
Cecile having a baby with Joe remember
when she came back into the past for the
baby shower appreciate the time that you
have while you have it implying that
something bad would happen to Joe and
Cecile in the future that
so probably feeds into what this mistake
of the future winds up being that she
makes so let me know in the comments
what are all your predictions for season
five don't worry we'll be doing more
season 5 videos through the summer flash
war just dropped I'll do a separate
video about that this weekend but also
big reminder like I said Titans is going
to be dropping their trailer and a bunch
of footage and stuff at Comic Con the
series doesn't have an official premiere
date but the rumor is is that it's all
gonna drop at the end of the summer
we'll probably wind up seeing most of
that before flash season 5 starts I will
be doing videos for that and then Young
Justice season 3 isn't supposed to
premiere til towards the end of the year
so I'll do more videos about that but
they'll also probably have some sort of
Comic Con footage to show off click here
for my finale video again and click here
to listen to Jessica Parker Kennedy
talked about Comic Con in season 5
related stuff thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight